outside of the the championships with
the lakers right what was in your turn
in your what was the best team you ever
were a part of let's just exclude kobe
in the lakers because obviously i mean
you got you got hardware for those the
best team i've ever played on
they're probably
kobe's just incredible but i think the
team will yeah
that y'all were y'all mean
like that wasn't he i just never seen
nothing like it like that guy is
different
playing with him was so easy to win
and this is like yeah
yeah yeah people forget like yumming had
a very short run but when he was
yao mean that [ __ ] was i've
never played anyone is dominant so was
tmac on that team as well t-mac was on
that team that's another big what if
right shane battier shane batty 18 was
kimbe mutombo
was um skip to milo on the right for
austin was on that team
rayford was nice an nba point guard he
was sick sure i never knew that it would
translate
but it translated he was like one of the
first street guys who i would watch on
anyone mixtapes who actually like did
real [ __ ] in the league he was a but he
was a real street dude right right right
right for you and rayford on the same
team had to be great the stories you
guys are probably sharing we we um yeah
i mean
but when i got to houston
it was more about business like rayford
is a bit he's about his business when it
comes to basketball like i didn't know
that about him
so we didn't get a chance to chat much
right i'm going to practice i'm going to
airport i'm going to hotel i'm going out
sometimes but for the most part i'm just
doing that so you don't get a chance to
share as many stories as i would have
liked to share a rafa but
i mean i grew up playing with him i mean
watching him mm-hmm um idolized them and
then to play on his team was incredible
and then yao ming so just talk about yao
ming you were saying a little bit
earlier like
what was it like having yao ming
as a teammate the guy made the all-star
team every year mm-hmm you know every
year he played he got voted in but like
he was an incredible player sometimes i
think we forget how good yao ming was
and how good the t-mac yao mean one-two
punch
with all those role players around him
was yeah yeah yeah but what was what was
yaming like as a teammate
great teammate um
[Music]
you know all the teammates is different
but yeah i was he was unique because he
was such a star
and i thought i was going to see
something different like maybe yeah i
have the big boy rolls royce you know i
mean like
maybe security and all this other stuff
and maybe don't practice total opposite
humble
coach uh rook adam would have to tell
him stop running so people do these
running drills after practice
and yao would do every drill yeah i
wouldn't set out no drills but that's
not typical
you could ask anybody right now on teams
when it's time to do suicides people
that are smaller than y'all
y'all ran every single suicide
but he didn't have to when he should not
have been running because he might have
had a longer career
and we needed him we need his energy but
yeah i was like nah if the if the bench
player is going to do it i'm going to do
it that's y'all me that's crazy yeah how
special was t-mac
t-mac was especially when i got with him
he was hurt he was he
he had already been kind of like down
his back and his knee was really bad
yeah yeah was he was he hard to defend
when you were had to defend him on the
other side really hard man i had some
lucky days i think against t-mac
um
[Music]
you know i had some lucky days against
t-mac but when t-mac was on
it was really difficult i mean he was
like a little small in durant maybe
three inches smaller than durant but two
inches taller than me
you know what i'm saying and smooth got
left hand right here left feet right
face three ball could drive
can pass
you know i'm saying tmac if you didn't
get hurt
you know i felt like he would have had a
really good career she and i'm you know
i feel like he would have had a karelia
kobe you know if he didn't get hurt
earlier for sure he got hurt in 2009 he
got hurt super early yeah yeah he was a
beast